right what's that my background looks
different I better do something about
that not better for you that actually
looks quite nice
[Music]
[Music]
Oh top common we'll decide what goes on
the wall giving you this power curse
with great power comes shitty
backgrounds what should I put on the
wall you tell me and if it's something
cancerous I'll still put it if it's
something horrifically offensive
oh but if it's your mama's [ __ ] I'll
still hoodie it's gonna be the best damn
wall you've ever seen who's gonna pay
for the wall
[Applause]
I ask you rose think you are clever you
think you're smarter than me probably
yeah no definitely definitely all right
let's see let's see what you got
bring it on gross so it's time for me to
read your rose holy [ __ ] there's a lot
of them you guys really didn't hesitate
a hundred thousand comments wow that's
just mean congratulations on being the
most overpaid man-child of 2016 hope 1
million comes faster than you do reading
cept applier fanfiction who knows maybe
2017 will halt some quality content but
let's get real the epitome of your
entertainment will be dick jokes for
twelve-year-olds now but seriously piers
I really enjoy your videos and I love
how much you have evolved you as a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] make up your mind I
thought for once we had a fan with a
little bit of stomach you're trying so
hard to be wannabe feel free thank that
actually makes me wish for your annoying
screaming at the camera for the lols
while playing some [ __ ] game content to
be back ok ok I want I want to I want to
be frank I want to make fun of disabled
people alright chay johansson actual
photo documentation of a big nerd woo
I'm such a nerd actual photo
documentation of a cry for attention
that's what I should say you're welcome
J in recent years B colonies around the
world have been collapsing at an
unprecedented rate a rate that is
alarming many food producers because it
affects every crop that depends on
direct depends directly or indirectly on
bees for population at present this is
done efficiently on free of charge by
bees but some scientists believe that if
bees continue to die out at the present
ray bees may disappear altogether within
a few years
sad react only
no more bees that's horrible
no more b-movie memes a lot how you say
that your content is better nowadays
when it's just a combination of
desperate filthy Frank copycat and you
two brands no one asked for just go back
to your gaming videos because it's the
only thing that you were good in life so
I was good at something
well thank you oh yeah don't forget the
clickbait title because that's the only
way people will be interested in you and
your [ __ ] all right mr. Reza all right
let me tell you ain't nothing
interesting about you and anything that
you oh my god is that a is that bread
and olive oil I take it all back
now this guy I can really take dick
that's good
haha this is not roasting this is just
being mean you guys are just me you have
to be funny otherwise to just leave not
sure why your channel was in my
recommended list maybe this is what
happens when you watch too many Animal
Planet
that's a good roast you know what Joelle
jaha Johar Mirage give you that one
you are pathetic I can't believe that
you fooled everyone that you're gonna
delete your channel when you reach 50
million subscribers oh did I told you is
that why but you did it little desperate
to reach your milestone of having 50
million subscribers it shows that you
are nothing but an attention seeker and
a greedy bastard
oh and by the way I'm glad you never
kick you out of your home old home due
to the fact that you scream like a
little girl whose vagina is being
stretched there needs to be a little bit
of comedy and like you just being mean
just just being mean okay
I don't what am I supposed to reply to
you Dave what am I supposed to say the
fact that your mustache it's a saddest
excuse of a mustache I've ever seen how
about that I bet your blonde hair is
[ __ ] died homosexual dick sucking
ball throbbing [ __ ] go get a dick cuz
apparently you can't get a life
[Music]
hello my name is her Easter lab guarana
of and I'm banging my sister you're so
[ __ ] that even YouTube well if you
can't properly conjugate the word
[ __ ] then you when you call someone
[ __ ] then you kind of failed
couldn't even get three words in right
Felix you seen his viewers to give him
new video ideas for his dying Channel
maybe he'll start gaining subscribers or
even get used through some way of
outside of click fading gullible viewers
you were better in 2012
oh wait that's not a roast that's the
truth 50,000 likes let's watch a video
from 2012 I'm Jay and NVIDIA let's just
see here we go here's a video from 2012
smack them titties
hello okay back up
how does taken smack that OH I kept
smacking to the grass stop China there
we go the dog shaped God you know we're
all right that's hilarious mmm
got ya dog shaped gun of justice huh
it's uh it's just cringe I don't get it
I don't get em you have 50 million
subscribers each video you have at least
three to four million years that's like
46 million people ignoring you every day
remove pew and pie and you'll get the
future of your channel I'm it's the old
pewds you know the one that wasn't
driven by sub count and YouTube awards
the simple Poots who made me laugh
hysterically seems like you killed him
up here's like one of those whiny
comments for no reason like I genuinely
don't care about sub counts anymore like
I've never watched it like back in
2013-14 I would watch my sub count
literally every single day like I don't
even care anymore like it's cool that we
hit fifty million but I mean it when I
say it's irrelevant and it's weird to me
how people for some reason pick up that
it's the complete opposite like this Jew
gene choy guy is like you've killed this
old piggy pie all you care about is subs
now before you would before you were
different but literally it's the
complete opposite I don't know I think
people just like to complain I think
people like to whine and make up their
own reason why oh hey Peter pie I
noticed recently you've been standing up
for little guys on YouTube pity you need
to need redtube to get your little guy
to stand up yeah see that's a roast
that's funny at least Thank You Adam
Norwood this is what I expected like
funny comments literally all I get
instead is like hey I love your videos
man Oh finally a nice comment you know
what for now I accept it I love all the
live streams you do and all the charity
work you've done now thank you I
appreciate that you enjoy especially
love your drunk minecraft and five
nights at freddy
oh wait that's mark
[Music]
PewDiePie more like shut up you drama
queen and are you trying to imitate
leafy stupid [ __ ]
I hope idubbbz gets your ass mark and
Jack the 7th motor subs than you
Edgar deserves a better owner Edgar what
do you say you love me right
please adopt me he abuses me for views
YouTube hates you so much that even the
pen pen Apple can guy had more screen
time YouTube people its crew Hey look at
that rose Michelle are you crying now
cuz I roasted you
no [ __ ] Smith I'm an [ __ ]
yeah who's crying now huh just [ __ ]
right just [ __ ] crying now this is
how you actually look like got him
you say you don't like your own videos
because you were trying too hard to be
funny well at least you were trying back
then oh damn damn my tears huh that was
good haha if someday a virus kills half
old world's population you would make a
video whining about the fact that one's
good now it's probably my favorite no
need to roast you you've already made
fun of yourself enough that 50 million
people will only watch you to feel
better about
[Music]
why did I even bother getting a new
office I what my channel is gone anyway
oh I have why does it burn what the [ __ ]
thank you guys for roasting me I think I
need it to stay humbled but maybe
sometimes you could say something nice
to me anyway uh check out this video
it's another roasting video it's kind of
like this one but not really and I made
it a long time ago so it's pretty much
irrelevant but I think you'd still enjoy
it so have a go have a look see what you
can find maybe click on a video even
after that one that would be cool that
would just be great
[Music]